hello and welcome to the gender it's
just a week to go before Parliament
breaks for the holidays and just in case
she might miss us over the summer here's
a look ahead at the Autumn term but is
it going to be any different jean-claude
juncker got the keys the Commission
presidency when mep voted for him in a
secret ballot but in order for our
commission president elect pass go he
has to hire his 18 elections to the
College of Commissioners kicks off in
October after the first round of
hearings at the end of September will
mr. young could be loving it when a plan
comes together or will it be back to the
drawing board to find his new soldiers
of fortune it'll be the big story around
Parliament after the break with a crisis
in Ukraine Iraq Gaza and now with the
downing of Malaysian flight mh17 because
the EU be set to raise the stakes in
foreign policy Russia's annexation of
Crimea has highlighted the division
between member states but after
russian-backed rebels were blamed for
downing a Malaysian plane killing all
298 people on board called for stronger
sanctions that will hurt President Putin
are growing louder a big test of
European will lies ahead kid Parliament
help find a common voice
with Italy at the helm of the rotating
council presidency of the EU a push from
more United response the migrant crisis
is on the way protecting borders is for
member states and member states alone if
overwhelmed they can then turn to
frontex the EU border security agency
but in southern Europe the problem is
the most acute Italy says it can't cope
with a thousands of migrants taking
desperate measures to cross the
Mediterranean a situation made worse
after the Arab Spring Italy's calls for
help from other member states has so far
fallen on deaf ears but with migration
being one of the presidencies hot
potatoes will they get the help they
need find out in September fighting over
the budget it's become all drag with an
eerie focusing from austerity to growth
could we see less toys being thrown from
the pram remember new programs can't be
created and added to yearly budget
everything is set out in the EU
seven-year budget but funds allocated
for 2015 need to find a new home with
job creation being a top priority for
the years ahead could we see a bigger
share go to Erasmus or employment and
don't forget a review of the long-term
budget is set for 2016 even bigger
changes to our money goes it could be on
the horizon the budget debate kicks off
in October three finalists one prize
will it be girlhood Ida or class enemy
with their hands on a lux prize find out
at the December plenary over to the
sakharov prize he will follow in the
footsteps of last year's winner Malala
yousufzai will know the candidates of
parliament humanitarian award after
summer and finally calling all lonely
hearts or should I say broken hands till
October Parliament plays host to the
museum of broken relationships gaze up
down there before it and
it's time to go green well greener since
the elections mepz been waxing lyrical
about climate change and energy security
parliament has been pushing to rapidly
reduce co2 emissions and make us a
low-carbon economy also as we import
more than sixty percent of our gas and
eighty percent of our oil another goal
has been to find new ways for year of a
source its energy supply there's a
solution lie in renewables the campaign
to make Europe 50 shades of green kicks
off in October and that's all we have
the agenda take care and enjoy the
holidays